"THE FIVE" ."
WHAT SHOULD WE EXPECT AS WE HEAD
TOWARD THE MUELLER HOMESTRETCH?
>> PEOPLE WHO ARE CLOSEST TO
WHAT MUELLER HAS BEEN DOING,
INTERACTING WITH THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL CAUTIONED ME THAT THIS
REPORT IS ALMOST CERTAIN TO BE
ANTICLIMACTIC.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT THE FBI WAS
INVESTIGATING IN THAT
"NEW YORK TIMES" REPORT, LOOK AT
WHAT THEY WERE INVESTIGATING,
MUELLER DID NOT GO ANYWHERE WITH
THAT INVESTIGATION.
HE SPENT WRITING HIS REPORT IN
REAL TIME THROUGH THESE
INDICTMENTS AND WE'VE SEEN
NOTHING FROM MUELLER ON THE
CENTRAL QUESTION OF WHAT IS
THERE ANY COORDINATION,
COLLUSION WITH THE RUSSIANS AND
THE EFFORT TO MEDDLE IN THE
ELECTIONS OR WAS THERE EVEN IN
THE KNOWLEDGE ON THE PART OF THE
PRESIDENT OR ANYBODY IN HIS
CAMPAIGN WITH WHAT THE RUSSIANS
WERE DOING?
>> Greg: HOLY CRUD.
I WORRY FOR THE POOR MEDIA EVERY
DAY.
THEY'VE BEEN EXPECTING A PONY
AND THEY MANNED UP WITH A USED
SLINKY.
BRING IN THE THERAPY LLAMAS.
COULD THE MOST IN-DEPTH SCANDAL
EVER BE SIMPLY A FIGMENT OF THE
IMAGINATION?
SHORT ANSWER: YES.
LONG ANSWER: HELL YES.
JONATHAN TURLEY SUGGESTS
COLLUSION IN THE DEEP STATE
NARRATIVE ARE BOTH
INTERPRETATIONS OF THE SAME
BUCKET OF FACTS.
COLORED BY OUR OWN BIASES.
SO WHICH IS TRUE, THAT TRUMP
CONCLUDED WITH PUTIN OR THERE IS
A SECRET GROUP UNDERMINING THE
PRESIDENT?
MAY BE NEITHER BUT THEY FEEL
TRUE TO BOTH SIDES.
ON ONE SIDE, THE FBI CHASED A
RUSSIAN STORY BECAUSE THAT'S HER
JOB.
THEY WERE TOLD THEY HAD TO DO
SOMETHING WHICH MEANT FIND
SOMETHING.
THEY ARE STILL LOOKING.
MEANWHILE, THE OTHER SIDE SEASON
ORCHESTRATED COUP AGAINST TRUMP
RUN BY OBSESSED NEVER TRUMP-ERS.
THEY BOTH FEEL RIGHT, ESPECIALLY
BECAUSE BIASES ARE EASILY
CONFIRMED WITH WHAT WE WANT TO
SEE IS PRESENTED IS SOMEHOW
TRUE.
IT'S TWO DIFFERENT SANDWICHES
MADE FROM THE SAME CRAP.
SMELLS LIKE PROFIT FROM
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND MSNBC.
IT'S SIMPLER.
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION, JUST
RUSSIANS DOING WHAT THEY DO WITH
THE DEEP STATE ABOUT AS
ORGANIZED AS AN EMOTIONAL CNN
PANEL.
IS THE OBVIOUS CONCLUSION AND IT
PLEASES NO ONE WHICH MAKES ALL
THE MORE LIKELY THAT IT'S TRUE.
ALL RIGHT, JUAN.
PREPARE TO BE DISAPPOINTED.
>> Juan: DEFLATED, LIKE AFTER
CHRISTMAS, THOSE BIG SANTAS AT
THE MALL.
YOU FEEL IT COMING?
I KEEP FEELING THESE BURSTS OF
AIR, LAST WEEK, SAYING THAT
METAPHOR IT WAS REVEALED IN FACT
WERE SHARING PRIVILEGED DATA
WITH THE RUSSIANS.
>> Jesse: NO, HE WASN'T.
THE UKRAINIAN ONE.
THEY RETRACTED THE RUSSIAN
CONNECTION.
>> Juan: IN FACT THE QUESTION
WAS BETWEEN THE UKRAINIAN AND
THE RUSSIANS, JESSE.
YOU GET THINGS LIKE THAT ARE
THEN YOU GET --
>> Greg: SCRAPS.
>> Juan: OVER THE WEEKEND
"THE WASHINGTON POST" REPORTED
THAT TRUMP WAS TELLING HIS
INTERPRETER GIVE ME THE NOTES.
DON'T TALK TO ANYBODY ABOUT IT.
>> Greg: IS THAT UNUSUAL?
I DON'T KNOW.
>> Juan: IT'S VERY UNUSUAL.
>> Greg: NOT FOR ME.
I TAKE ALL MY NOTES.
BUSINESSMEN DON'T LIKE PEOPLE
TAKING NOTES.
>> Dana: I WOULD BE OKAY WITH
YOU AS PRESIDENT.
>> Greg: OH, OH, OH.
I'M NOT BEING PRESIDENT BECAUSE
THEN ALL OF MY FRIENDS GO DOWN,
AS WE'VE LEARNED.
>> Juan: IT WILL BE A HIGH
MARK QUOTIENT.
>> Greg: CAN I PLAY YOU
"VIEW?"
>> ON THE CENTRAL QUESTION OF DO
DONALD TRUMP OR ANYBODY IN HIS
CAMPAIGN COORDINATE, COLLUDE
WITH THE RUSSIANS IN THEIR
EFFORT TO MEDDLE IN THE 2016
CAMPAIGN?
WE HAVE SEEN ZERO EVIDENCE OF
THAT.
PAUL MANAFORT HAS BEEN INDICTED
BECAUSE OF HIS PERSONAL
CORRUPTION.
>> YOU ARE SAYING THERE IS NO
INDICATION BUT MUELLER HAS KEPT
THIS INVESTIGATION VERY CLOSE TO
THE VEST.
THERE MAY BE NO INDICATION NOW
THAT WE DON'T REALLY KNOW
BECAUSE HE'S BEEN VERY GOOD AT
THAT.
>> WE DON'T KNOW WHAT WE DON'T
KNOW.
BUT WE KNOW A LOT.
>> Greg: JESSE COME HE'S
TRYING TO BREAK IT TO HIM LIKE
HE'S BREAKING UP WITH HIM.
TRUMP JUST YELLED AT HIM OVER
THE WEEKEND.
>> Jesse: THAT WAS PENCE, BUT
THEY PROBABLY BOTH YELLED AT
HIM.
I'M NOT GOING TO SAY ANYTHING
DISPARAGING ABOUT "THE VIEW."
VERY GOOD SHOW.
>> Greg: YOU ARE NEVER GOING
TO BE ON IT, TRY AS YOU MIGHT.
>> Jesse: WE'LL SEE.
I HAD AN UNCLE, AND THIS WAS HIS
PHILOSOPHY.
HE ASSUMED EVERYONE HE MET WAS A
CHILD MOLESTER AND THAT HE
WORKED BACK FROM THAT ASSUMPTIO
ASSUMPTION.
HE ASSUMED THE WORST ABOUT
EVERYBODY.
THIS IS MY POINT.
MY POINT IS THE FBI ASSUMED
TRUMP WAS A PUPPET OF PUTIN AND
THAT'S WHAT BAKES INTO
EVERYTHING THEY DO.
WHEN TRUMP CAME IN, HE WASN'T
REALLY GOING AFTER RUSSIA.
HE THOUGHT CHINA WAS THE BIGGEST
NATIONAL SECURITY THREAT.
THAT'S A DIFFERENCE OF OPINION
BUT THEY CRIMINALIZED IT.
THEY SAID HACK LOOK AT HILLARY.
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THOSE
EMAILS.
IT WAS A JOKE.
IT WASN'T AN ACTUAL ATTEMPT TO
HACK.
THE FBI CULTURE IS A VERY
RUSSIAN-INFLUENCE CULTURE.
THEY'VE BEEN FIGHTING THE
COLD WAR FOR TWO GENERATIONS.
IF A BUSINESSMAN COMES IN A
DOESN'T PLAY BALL WITH THE
CONVENTIONAL WISDOM OF
WASHINGTON ESTABLISHMENT, THEY
AUTOMATICALLY ASSUME HE'S A
RUSSIAN SPY.
SO WHEN THEY HAVE THIS THING,
THERE'S THIS RUMOR THAT THEY
CHANGED, AT THE RNC, THE G.O.P.
PLATFORM AGAINST UKRAINE, THAT
WAS FAKE NEWS.
THEY NEVER DID.
THEY NEVER WATERED IT DOWN.
ACTUALLY MADE IT TOUGHER AGAINST
RUSSIA.
WHEN DONALD TRUMP COMES IN, HE
FIRES COMEY AND THEY THINK COMEY
IS A PRINCE.
YOU CAN'T TOUCH HIM.
COMEY AND HIS MINIONS HAVE BEEN
FIRED, INDICTED, DEMOTED.
THEY ARE UP ON CHARGES, JUAN.
THEY'VE HAD THEIR TEXT MESSAGES
DESTROYED SUSPICIOUSLY.
THESE PEOPLE ASSUME DONALD TRUMP
WAS A RUSSIAN PUPPET AND WORKED
BACK FROM THERE.
I THINK IT'S A VERY DANGEROUS
AND NAIVE THING --
>> Juan: I WILL BE BRIEF AND
SAY I THINK BEFORE THE ELECTION
IN 2016, THERE WERE FOUR TRUMP
ASSOCIATES UNDER INVESTIGATION
FOR THEIR TIES TO RUSSIA.
>> Jesse: WHY DIDN'T THEY
PROTECT THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN?
WHY DIDN'T THE FBI GIVE THEM A
WARNING AND SAY THE RUSSIANS
MIGHT TRY TO INFLUENCE THINGS.
MAYBE YOU COULD LOOK OUT FOR IT.
INSTEAD, THEY TRIED TO TRAP THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
>> Juan: DIDN'T GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS IN LONDON TELL THE
AUSTRALIAN AMBASSADOR WE HAVE
INFORMATION.
>> Greg: IF PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
A RUSSIAN AGENT AND WHO SAYS
HE'S NOT, DO YOU THINK MUELLER
WOULD NOT HAVE ACTED AT THE
FIRST SIGN OF EVIDENCE.
INSTEAD OF SAYING NO, I'M GOING
TO TAKE MY TIME WITH THIS
INVESTIGATION.
>> Dana: BILL BARR,
PRESIDENT'S NOMINEE FOR ATTORNEY
GENERAL, HE SAYS IN THE
PRETESTIMONY I'M GOING TO LET
MUELLER FINISH HIS JOB BUT HE
REFERS TO HIM AS BOB.
THEY KNOW EACH OTHER.
I THINK IF MUELLER DID NOT DO A
THOROUGH INVESTIGATION, THE LEFT
WOULD NEVER BE SATISFIED.
HE'S GOT TO DO ALL THE RIGHT
THINGS.
JONATHAN KARL IS A VERY GOOD,
RESPONSIBLE JOURNALIST.
HE COULD MAKE YOU MAD TOO ONCE
IN A WHILE BUT REALLY FAIR.
THE THING IS, WHAT'S WORSE FOR
DEMOCRATS?
PRESIDENT TRUMP BEING A RUSSIAN
AGENT OR PRESIDENT TRUMP NOT
BEING A RUSSIAN AGENT.
THAT'S WHAT YOU HAVE TO ASK
YOURSELF.
>> Greg: GOOD QUESTION.
KATIE, DO YOU THINK THE MEDIA
HAS THEIR SHARE OF BLAME AND
RAISING EXPECTATIONS?
>> Katie: NO, THEY HAVE BEEN
TOTALLY RESPONSIBLE ABOUT THEIR
REPORTING ON THE RUSSIAN
INCIDENT.
THIS IS LIKE THE BIGGEST
CONSPIRACY THEORY EVER FROM THE
LEFT.
THE FACT THAT WE ARE DISCUSSING
WHETHER THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AS A RUSSIAN
AGENT, A GUY WHO ALLEGEDLY HAD
THE MOST INCOMPETENT CAMPAIGN IN
THE HISTORY OF AMERICA SOMEHOW
MAKES IT INTO THE WHITE HOUSE
AND NOW ALL OF A SUDDEN HE'S
COMPETENT ENOUGH TO NOT ONLY GET
INTO THE WHITE HOUSE BUT TO BE A
DOUBLE AGENT FOR THE
UNITED STATES AND FOR THE
RUSSIANS.
IT'S QUITE AMAZING.
BUT ON THE DOUBLE STANDARD, WHEN
YOU READ "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
STORY ABOUT WHY THE FBI OPENED
THIS COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION WHICH BY THE WAY
THEY CAN OPEN ON ANYBODY FOR ANY
REASON APPARENTLY.
THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE IN THE
PIECE CITED ABOUT WHY THEY DID
THAT.
MY QUESTION IS IF THEY ARE DOING
IT BASED ON A CHANGE IN POLICY
TOWARDS RUSSIA WHICH IS WHAT
THEY USED FOR JUSTIFICATION, CAN
YOU IMAGINE IF THE FBI OPENED
ACCOUNT OR INTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION ON BARACK OBAMA
FOR BEING AN URANIUM OPERATIVE
-- IRANIAN OPERATIVE BECAUSE OF
WHAT HE WAS GIVING TO IRAN IN
TERMS OF CASH.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF THAT WAS AN
OFFICIAL THING OPEN ON THE BASIS
OF POLICY, NOT ACTUAL EVIDENCE?
THE QUESTION IS THERE'S A LOT OF
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN COMPLAINING
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT ATTACKING
THE FBI, THAT CREDIBILITY OF THE
INSTITUTION BUT THEY'VE DONE
NOTHING TO REESTABLISH THE
CREDIBILITY WHEN IT COMES TO
THEM DEFENDING THE FBI IN
OPENING UP THIS
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION WITHOUT ANY KIND
OF EVIDENCE WHATSOEVER.
>> Juan: I THINK THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME IN AMERICAN HISTORY
THE FBI HAS DONE IT.
YOU CAN'T SAY THEY DO IT --
SECONDLY.
HERE'S THE THING.